pierre a emménagé dans son appartement
flambant neufs en juillet dernier mais
depuis plus de quatre mois il est sans
connexion internet résultat ils se
retrouvent sans accès téléphonique sans
accès à la toile et sans possibilité de
pouvoir bénéficier d'une offre de
chaînes payantes ce retraité bénévole
dans une association humanitaire
international est bloqué dans sa
communication quotidienne aujourd'hui
j'ai 50 % communication qui est
endommagé puisque aujourd'hui si vous
voulez aujourd'hui on n'a fait que
internet deviennent si vous voulez un
moyen de communication au niveau mondial
et j'ai pas accès j'ai pas accès ni à
travers mon ordinateur j'ai pas accès ni
à travers mon téléviseur je suis désolé
mais c'est pas acceptable
je suis vice-président fin past
président d'une association humanitaire
est bon bien souvent j'ai des opérations
à faire notamment avec l'étranger et je
suis enquiquiner avec ça j'ai
l'impression que orange ne se rend pas
compte du
[Musique]
du service qu'il doit rendre à l'homme
le promoteur de cet immeuble multiplie
les démarches depuis sa livraison en
juillet dernier sans pour autant avoir
de date précise sur l'entamé des travaux
et du raccordement vous êtes avides de
vie sains pour le réseau adsl et un pour
le réseau fibré pour une somme globale
de 6100 euros et environ au centime près
et devait réaliser ces travaux pour
juillet à la date de livraison aux
différents acquéreurs et malheureusement
nous sommes en novembre et les travaux
n'ont toujours pas été réalisée si fait
si bien qu' aucun locataire propriétaire
résidant ne peut bénéficier du téléphone
de l'internet du réseau qui peut
endroit est effectivement avoir dans
cette ville de seine-et-marne ses 11 co
propriétaires se bat toujours pour avoir
accès à internet certains se sont même
isolé et devrait demander une
compensation à orange la fracture
numérique touche bel et bien les grandes
villes du pays et pourrait peut-être
devenir l'un des enjeux de la prochaine
campagne présidentielle